is how you make matcha Mochi toast
first things first we gotta make the
Mochi your sweet rice flour this is the
brand I use sugar and water mix well
until nice and smooth I cover with a
plastic wrap now we're going to
microwave this for one minute after a
minute in the microwave we're going to
stir this up and we're going to
microwave again for one minute we're
gonna mix again for the second time and
for the last time we're gonna microwave
this for 30 seconds all right for my
bread I'm using brioche but you can use
any bread you want now get the Mochi and
spread it as evenly as possible in low
heat we're going to melt some butter
we're going to gently toast the brioche
the sweet cream equal parts condensed
milk and equal parts heavy cream you can
also use milk or water cover it matcha
powder sweet red beans I got the canned
ones this is not homemade the drizzle
with the sweet cream ever since I had
this in K-Town I had to recreate it